[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome to Piers Morgan I'm censored
with me Jeremy Carr now coming up
tonight 25 years since the death of
Princess Diana the question is will
Meghan Markle ever be able to replace
her in people's hearts good cop mad cop
is it time that our police wake up and
solve some real crimes and hunger shapes
the utter disgrace of children turning
up to school with an empty stomach in
21st century Britain
I spend as much time taking food away
from children as I do serve in it and to
be honest it's not what I took the job
for you know I never dreamed that I'd be
having to tell children you can't have
that you've no money on your account
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
good evening my friends welcome to
uncensored now this very hour 25 years
ago the Royal flight bearing Diana
Princess of Wales coffin arrived back in
London draped in the Royal Standard as
she made her final trip home the grief
and the loss felt around this country
and the world I think changes forever it
took almost 20 years for the royal
family to find someone else who could
bring the glitz and the glamor that
Princess Di provided Meghan Markle and
Outsider like Diana appeared at first to
be just that person to refresh the firm
and bring it into the 21st century but
it hasn't quite worked out that way I
remember Blair saying on that fateful
day that the public everywhere not just
here in Britain kept Faith with Princess
Diana but there are already signs that
the public have lost faith in Megan
Diana Spence was undoubtedly the
original people's princess but what to
the people of today make of this version
I went to Windsor Castle this morning
where Charles proposed Diana to find out
25 years ago today Diana died Saturday
the whole world in mourning one word
that in your mind would stand up Diana
oh she was amazing personally amazing
she did the job and uh decided I have to
say she should beat your code in here so
but yeah incredible human brilliant and
I was on my way to work and I just read
the papers and I said it can't be true
and it was a shock I thought she was the
most wonderful princess she was a
beautiful lady I I met her and I was in
awe of her I thought she was amazing
what do you think the people's princess
would have said to her son or Meghan
Markle about what's going on
I think she would have preferred case
because I think Kate's lovely and she's
really kind and nice I think Megan's a
little bit in it for herself and what do
you think Diana would have made a marker
what would she have said
that you go on girl what word would you
describe Meghan Markle as oh
do we have to don't like her
one word that sums up Meghan Markle
I I feel for her to be honest yeah I do
yeah I just think that
just been really hard on her and I I
agree with Harry I agree with their
decisions and their choices I think it
was the right thing to do to get her out
of there before history like he said
started to repeat herself
so a cross-section of opinion Johnny
mano's talk radio's Royals correspondent
Rupert Bell uh Princess Diana's friend
Sally Morgan who worked with her for
nearly five years in the 90s and lawyer
Paula Roan Adrian ladies and Rupert
welcome Sally can I start with you
um
I found it really strange I live in
Windsor I went up to the castle today to
just gauge opinion and I almost found
this generational
reaction if I'm honest the older
generation called a beautiful wonderful
inspirational and caring and have no
time for Meghan Markle the younger
generation would say to me we don't
really know too much except for what
we've watched on the crown but we feel
sorry for Megan
who was Diana the woman that you knew
what made her so special in your mind
well I think that she was um she and she
turned out to be very outspoken she she
was one of the first people to talk
about her mental health and mental
health she was one of the first
prominent people to embrace individuals
with AIDS she was somebody that stood up
for the underdog and I also think that
people could see her pain I certainly
could see her and I saw it on a daily
basis was she inspirational I think she
was I mean she was inspiration for so
many people for for so many women at
that time that were having difficulties
in their marriage in their relationships
you know if the Princess of Wales can
divorce the Prince of Wales if that can
happen then I can certainly leave my
husband who isn't treating me too well
or he's having an affair so I think that
she was an inspiration to many people
um Paula to bring you in
um Meghan Markle has by anybody's
standards
um
caused so much reaction and let's be
honest a lot of it negative you could
feel that today on the streets you read
it almost every day I think she's caused
a negative reaction I do think that the
Press have reacted negatively my problem
my problem with that and I said it last
night and the reason we're doing it is
because it is it is everywhere and it's
what people want to talk about here's
what I'm going to say and I'll say it
again if you don't want to be in the
royal family because you don't want the
Press exposure and you don't like every
facet of your life being interrogated I
get that you go to California with the
love of your life and you have two
children you don't land and sign a deal
with Spotify and this is the bit that
really gets on my bits if I'm being
completely honest every single time
there is something that matters to the
Royal Family Life the death of Prince
Philip like you know today the 25th
anniversary what does old Meghan Markle
do drop her latest truth bomb it's a
podcast it's true her timing is Dreadful
Paul yeah I know I think it is I think
that uh you know listen days is what
happens the negativity just runs right
what's the fact I'm going to say a
negative I'm going to jump on the
bandwagon and say a negative when we
talk about facts I think what we're
missing here is reality you described
Diana so beautifully and I would say
that I could describe Megan in exactly
the same way well we could just I could
describe Megan in that way but if you
look at that forget what she's done to
the royal family it's not what she's
done to the royal family let's she
remembers who has I don't I don't know
her what I do know is that the message
the very clear message that we are
getting reported to us is that she's a
bully that she's aggressive that she's
taken over Harry's life as if he's some
weak individual and yet we forget that
his own mother was forced to flee this
country she herself was planning to move
to LA she herself had decided to begin a
relationship with somebody who didn't
look like her who didn't talk like her
who didn't come from a family that fit
into the establishment and this is what
you're asking of Megan she wasn't
prepared for this and neither were the
establishment The Establishment got it
wrong with Diana they got it wrong with
Andrew
let me bring in let me bring in Rupert
Bell if I can talk to the Israel
correspondent he shared a goddaughter
with Diana and knows through his family
his brother trains for the queen many
links Cold Stream guards as well Rupert
you're very you know you you always play
it very straight down the line what did
you respect what was your response to
what I said about Meghan Markle like her
or lothra it seems to me that she drops
this stuff at the exact moment to cause
as much embarrassment and hurt to the
royal family as possible
it does all her timing is horrendous and
but she has created this we when we went
to the wedding the Groundswell of public
opinion was so much in her favor and yet
she has managed and to end up basically
painting this picture that everything is
everybody else's fault it's never her
fault and I think that's part of the
problem it always seems to say that
ex-member of the royal family has done
this that member of the reform role fact
is done that she has not done anything
wrong and I think that's what's
frustrating people why does she always
feel the need to pay the victim as she
sits in her 14 million dollar Villa in
in California when most of us can't you
know worried about whether they're going
to get food on the table so I really do
think she needs to start reading the
room and realize that what she is saying
most of the time doesn't resonate with
most of the British public Paula that's
quite an interesting point of ruperts
how would you respond to that quite
easily we talk about this Groundswell as
if we can dictate what others think I
don't know what the society thinks
because it's not being reported what I'm
being told is that that's what people
think but your own report has just
informed us that actually there's a lot
of people out there who have sympathy
for yeah absolutely and I said I suspect
I started by saying this generation I
genuinely believe that absolutely
um and I wonder if it's because of where
people are getting their information
from and if it is generational which I
think is probably right
um there is the younger generation that
get their information get their news
from other places absolutely the older
generation who get their news from
different places and who trust where
they get their news I'm not doubting
that but you haven't answered the
question and a supporter of fairhagen of
her last night also did not answer the
question do you not think there is
something in the fact in my opinion
there is we're all entitled opinion that
every time Prince Philip died today is
the 25th anniversary of Diane the queen
is ill she keeps dropping this stuff via
third and fourth parties there's lots to
be I'm not saying she might have a case
I'm not saying it wasn't hard I'm not
saying that there have been people who
have said and done things massively
unfair to her I absolutely can see the
comparisons but I absolutely when I look
at those pictures of the two of them in
the uh the die in a picture in the black
polar neck and her as well Diana looks
vulnerable lost scared Meghan Markle
looks straight down the camera and looks
like I've got this absolutely licked I
don't she she doesn't create sympathy in
me that's the problem and and let me
tell you why because let me answer the
question because you answer the question
yourself but your tone is very quiet
when you did I noticed that you said
that the bombs are dropped by some third
or fourth party person Omar Schmidt or
something we're not suggesting are we
that this is Megan that is putting out
this information
come on and then secondly even if she
did deny it where are we going to read
that why do you think are you with me
this bizarre article that came out in in
I think it was 2021 forgive me if I've
got the date wrong where it referenced
but in very in lots of detail about the
approach that is taken in relation to
Megan as opposed to the approach that is
taken to lovely is that because of the
color of the skin seriously I don't know
you tell me I'm interested in what you
say to that I mean she will tell you yes
archetypes yesterday you heard the
podcast she said that she felt that she
was treated as a as a black woman only
when she married her prince
um and that's of course in any way if
that's right that's fundamentally wrong
I've said that from day one I just can't
Sally get away from I'm just being
honest I cut see Rupert makes a really
really good point how does that look and
sound right now with this country on the
precipice of economic disaster
absolutely but I do think that when you
look at Megan and you look at how she is
the one on that really is controlling
Harry there's absolutely no doubt she is
I mean no she is Paula Harry she was
specific no but Harry and utterly in
love with her when you really really
love someone you will do anything for
them she recognizes that she refused she
looked at the system she refused to bow
to her brother-in-law and her
sister-in-law she could not understand
I'll tell you what I want to bring onto
it I want to ring group it back in
because I like the three of you to to
answer this next question Rupert what
would Diana the people's princess and
let's be honest flawed let's be honest
with her ex-husband both use the media
systematically my old man worked for the
Queen Mother and he said that everybody
after the queen has used the media what
would Diana have have said about Megan
when I was out and about today at
Windsor Castle half of the people were
saying she'd have taken her under the
wing she'd have felt sorry for the other
half was saying she would have been
gutted for her son and her brother and
his brother had split up over this woman
and she had taken action what would you
say Rupert
I think she would have tried to give
Megan all the advice and would have
probably been around to actually explain
the pitfalls that are likely to come her
way and realize what joining the firm is
all about now I don't know whether they
were briefed enough but the Dutch Meghan
Markle said that she wasn't briefed
which she knew all about it when you go
in and are going to be definitely a
member of the royal family it's pretty
it comes out pretty quickly and I think
that's what she would have done she
would have and she would have had plenty
of experience good bad indifferent
whatever to bring to the table because
remember she came to the royal family as
a 19 year old very inexperienced young
lady a big age gap between her and her
husband whereas Megan was a a lady of
the world being an actress being out
there already married before so much
more experienced there was a naivety
about Diana in the early stages because
of the way the royal family was at the
time that then changed and she became a
force you know not all always a force
you know she was flawed as you referred
to Jeremy but she did though still have
the well-being of her children
completely at the center
can I saw that throughout her life I
agree can I just say that that
I mean I I actually I'm going to
disagree with you and Rupert a little
bit because and I know this from the old
man there is absolutely no preparation
for going into the royal family I and
the reason you're nodding I yeah I don't
care who you are you can give them a
list from A to Z I'm sure absolutely the
fact that's not my point my point is
to me and we will differ but that's
human nature it's a democracy right she
used to stand outside Buckingham Palace
I'm utterly convinced this was her big
plan I'm utterly convinced she went for
this I'm being completely serious and I
just I think what it is is I've said
about that picture there's no
vulnerability this she doesn't link with
people in my humble opinion she's not
vulnerable that's the reason sorry Paul
with one vulnerability genuine
vulnerability you can see it you can see
it it's palpable who has walked into the
establishment I am telling you whether
you can see it on her face or not we are
very used to walking into situations
where we have to put on off do you think
she knew it was going to be like that
absolutely notes absolutely not she
would have gone in there with her Rose
tinted glasses I'm gonna be a princess
and I'm going to float around and this
is going to be amazing that's how she
approached this and she got so rude
awakening and can I say just to answer
the question that Rupert got the
opportunity to yeah you asked what would
Diana have done yeah Diana would have
been living with Megan in L.A no she
wouldn't have done that's where they
would no words that's what Diana needed
to do and I think we're forgetting how
the Press treated Diana
you were her friend what would she have
done I would say her friend I I spoke to
her every day for four and a half years
um you're never really their friend
Jeremy as we were just saying no but
basically I think that she would the
most the priority for Diana now would be
that her boys were not a strange yeah
that would have been and if that would
have meant that she would have had to
have pretended to try and in some way
counsel Megan she would have you've got
to remember also that Diana yes she was
naive when she married the Prince of
Wales but she was aristocratic she'd
been brought up
she knew and her sisters who counseled
her knew the system so you never know
until you're in there as I've just said
to you never their friends never ever
even aristocratic people even other
Royals are never really their friends
there is this they're they're in a
bubble that's why William at the moment
and Catherine they're in do you can I
can I just say and I think it's I think
I'm really pleased that we've spoken
like this because I think it was for me
really interesting to see the reaction
today from people one final question
surprised were you expecting total
negativity yeah yeah really good
question really good question and and
what shocked me most was three teenage
girls I thought they were 20 who said
well we've seen it on the crown which
just blew my mind so to speak the three
of the historical programs
three of you we'll start with Rupert
ladies first do you think that the
British public will ever take Meghan
Markle to their hearts
as Diana undoubtedly Flaws and All was
taken yes or no Roo
uh not in her present form she's going
to have to learn to
um not always be knocking the
institution that has been around since
1066 the the royal family may be a
flawed institution at times but there's
only one person who matters and that is
the reigning monarch the rest had to do
her bidding and you've got to work
around it and Megan needed to learn how
to work around it and cope with the fact
that Harry was six in light of the
throne and was in essence an extra to
the main members of the royal family
Charles and William they were but bit
part players thank you Rupert Paula
final word
I'm a member of the British society and
I accept her to my heart good for you
Sally well and we have to accept her
she's married to Harry but I think that
the the general public she's she's a
very headstrong manipulative
um she's very manipulative Paul other
people would say independent she's a
business woman well right so there's
your point and I've run out of time but
did she look about this whole thing as a
business there you are it's a very
interesting question
I can tell you she was in us a divorcer
oh God nobody told me that you could
have told me that a while ago are we
paying her for this right thank you
ladies thank you Rupert next and
uncensored now they danced the Macarena
but how about they try a bit of Smooth
Criminal instead the big question on
many papers today have the police given
up on solving crimes or coming back in
three and uncensored don't go anywhere
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
my friends welcome back and it's time to
bring some lore and order to the
uncensored studio now the police are
quite rightly expected to fight crime
and keep us safe but over the last few
weeks many have become uneasy as
senseless violence seems to become the
norm up and down our country and Lawless
Britain is running out of control it
seems now a damning report today by the
policy exchange think tankers accuse the
police of being too distracted from
tackling crime by woke causes whatever
that means it's not apparently like the
police have time to take part in random
acts of dancing on the street is it or
giving water to Thirsty protesters
stopping people getting to work and
don't forget Britain's wokis police
officer here modeling a rainbow hat we
must remember there are ten thousand
fewer Bobbies on the beat than there
were 12 years ago and here's one of the
potential new recruits a very honorable
upstanding member of society
do you think the police awoke prime
minister
I I tell you what they've seen a bunch
of police officers who who woke quite a
lot of drug dealers this morning and
they woke them long before they were
expecting to have their uh their
breakfast they were in their work they
woke them uh with uh with warrants and
they woke them with the news that they
were under arrest for uh causing misery
uh in in the communities of of luck
so the question we're asking is are the
police in this country too woke joining
me now is Kevin Hurley former police and
crime commissioner uh benedibong chair
of the haringay independent stop and
search monitoring group you try saying
that and tonight's uh Jesus jealous the
legend that is James whale and political
commentator Marina perkis uh welcome
welcome welcome
um let's start with you if I can Kevin
Hurley former Surrey police and crime
commissioner
um
I've spoken to many people Andy cook
Peter blexley they all say the same
thing the problem with the police
nowadays is apart from this few of them
they spend so much time doing jobs about
social care and mental health and
dealing with all the things that they
have to deal with that they're not on
the streets they're not getting
intelligence they're not finding out
what's going on in the community and as
a result they are not able to do their
jobs but when we see them mucking around
like that what are people supposed to
think well I first of all the first
point you're making there is absolutely
correct because they are filling in the
gaps where Social Services mental health
have effectively collapsed in National
Health Service they are spending huge
amounts of time in dealing with a lot of
those cases and the other point about
that is because of the fact there's so
much inspection of what police do now
they have to put asset or people looking
after mentally ill people in hospital
and so on but back to your point the
message we're seeing there of people
dancing the Macarena and so on whilst
for some it might be seen to be positive
at this particular time I don't think
that's a good message
the reason why I say that is that they
were at the LGBT Festival where they
they did that there are a number of
extremist groups who would like to pick
on LGBT people and the reason why the
police are there is to ensure the safety
of people attending that far better if
those four officers there were actually
engaging with people chatting with
people but separate from each other
keeping their eyes out and looking and
doing their job be vigilant Marina what
do you make of the police in this
country right now
I think they're doing the best they can
given they have been underfunded for 10
plus years by successive Tory
governments who slashed it by 23 000 by
the way 600 police stations closed not
to forget not debate our courts the
courts that are closed on our Judicial
System well you see that though the
Macarena what'd you make of that I don't
care are you trying to tell are people
trying to say that there was a crime
gone over here and they're too busy
doing the macaroni and so the crime
happened it's just not it's reductive
nonsense and we need to grow up and get
away from this this type of conversation
James
um you said to my team I think the
people running the police have ruined
the force what do you mean by that I do
I think there are two types of police I
have great respect for the armed police
the anti-terrorist squads the people who
do serious pleasing I have absolutely no
respect for those guys doing the dancing
they wouldn't protect me from crime I'd
have to protect myself there are waste
of space the Bobbies I see on the beat
quite often they look
unshaven dishriveled they've got their
shirts hanging now under their stab
vests they're short some of them others
are fat they're not a police force
anymore they're a police service and
what we need I don't want to be a friend
of the police I don't want them to be my
friend I want them to be there to solve
crime and protect me that is their job
now you say and and this is something
that I want to bring you on uh Bennett
in a state you say that everyone should
be prepared to be stopped and searched
now a lot of people certainly in Lawless
Britain we saw the horrendous situation
in Liverpool suddenly the police are on
the streets pulling gangsters left right
and Center we know about county lines we
know about gangs that we know about the
drug wars and knives and guns
surely stop and search with respect gets
weapons and knives off the streets why
what's your view of that
well I think Jeremy that uh no one in
the uh the community the black community
in particular are actually saying that
stop and search should not be used we're
not saying that at all we're saying it
should be used but when it is used it
should be used effectively appropriately
and on the basis of intelligence
policing and very often what we find is
that it's a sort of a scatter gun
approach where people are stopped in the
street there's no intelligence about any
indiscriminate indiscriminately
um and and the impact of that is that it
annoys and upsets those people who are
going about their daily business
lawfully
um and I mean there's a long history of
this going on in the black community
there is and I have to say my producer
one of the well is it the editor would
be upset if I said producer was telling
me today his mother's a teacher and she
teaches this teenage black boy and uh
eight times he's been stopped in the
last 12 weeks and he comes School
devastated I I think it's fundamentally
wrong if anything like that is pitched
today a person's color creed or race but
I have to say that last year the Met
police took 5 000 weapons off the
Streets of London so there is an
argument in Lawless Britain to do more
isn't there yeah I mean you know let's
get this in perspective stop and search
is all about first of all the quality of
the contact between the individual
officer sure and the person being
stopped and searched that's a very
difficult thing to do because often
teenagers whether black or white start
to become quite difficult and quite
assertive and as we've heard earlier not
all the police officers are huge uh
people they're scared they get scared
themselves and so very quickly
it can start to go bad but let me just
give you a couple of stats because I I
oversaw operation blunt 2 in 2008 for
the Metropolitan Police in that year we
had 29 teenage murders in London
four years later we were down to eight
teenage murders a year in London now
what's important about a murder victim a
teenage murder victim is
it's not just one parent that Grieves
it's usually three or four parents that
grieve when one gets murdered because
the other three get caught and get life
imprisonment what I want to know is
what's the answer Marina what is the
answer I mean are the police
um
are they undertrained underprepared
because of lack of funding is the
recruitment process wrong or they're not
the beliefs there were before I mean I I
I'm not being rude when we were kids
think you'd back me up here if you
thought the policing was going to take
you home and tell your mum you were
terrified people don't give a damn
anymore do they I don't know they do in
this idea going back to what you said
there James that what you need to see
someone with like an armed armed rifle
or something absolutely but that's
that's indicative of you and what you
need to be managed as a person most of
us don't need that we can throw it back
at me
that Law Abiding Citizen you might need
it I certainly don't no I'm saying I
don't need it I know you said I did need
it yourself
I don't need it you see Authority
physically there is no Authority I can
look after myself but there are lots of
people who can't I don't want to have to
look after myself really it's not my job
and I probably get into more trouble but
I want to see police when when I ring up
and say I've had my car stolen
I wanna I do too and why aren't they why
aren't they there because they are so
full of of of of these you know they've
got to have five coppers to arrest one
person one for each arm one for each leg
in the head in case they damage them
listen if you think that's that's what
it is you don't think it's the fact that
we had to shut down half of our police
station was the worst prime minister
we've had for many many years thank
goodness she's gone but I don't think we
have anybody in charge of the police I
think we should get rid of half of the
police forces we don't need this many we
need I'd like to see better quality is
what you're saying
who's going to be a police officer well
there's the point I'm making is it an
attractive opposite proposition anymore
to people it's no respect no I can tell
you now that please please pay for basic
councils who joined was cut by over six
thousand yeah which is exactly what
Marine is and the problem so then you go
back to her and you talk about funding
and he's right because they're they're
recruiting anybody and there isn't the
respect and there isn't there that's
what we're saying right well you know
that at the moment the information that
I'd have uh I'm involved in uh police
training locally uh certainly in
haringey Borough and the the new recruit
they come onto the borough we have a
workshop with them where we talk to them
about the history of haringey in
particular we talked to them about the
the chain of events and as a result what
they're likely to be met with when
they're out there policing people do you
think the quality sadly out I could sit
with you look all nice brilliant do you
think the quality of policing and the
job they're doing is good enough right
now
I think they have taken a serious hit
when their the major Cuts were made yes
and we know who was responsible for that
yep um and what the police are now
trying to do is to catch up and they're
trying to catch up with lower with with
fewer numbers yeah than they had
previously and that's creating a real
Gap in terms of response policing for
example you know people are phoning up
and they're reporting that I mean yeah
yeah I have to finish but we're really
aren't we Marina every day quick please
everybody but you know a thousand
anything under a thousand pounds the
police don't come out that's not good
enough there is a point to what he's
saying we should know and think and
believe that we can be protected and go
to this people but you're saying it's
funding right absolutely responding and
also we've got situations like Lambeth
superintendents said that on one evening
75 to 80 of calls were nothing to do
with crime they were police officers
going to suicide and going to mental
health crises we've got please go into
cardiac arrest so we are back where we
are the police man and woman is not on
the street not getting Intel not dealing
with the community because they're too
busy filling out what computer forms and
Ticking boxes and and they're not doing
so everybody actually essentially Chris
I would love under trained is a major
issue at everything
both right okay listen I have to move on
thank you Kevin Hurley uh benedibong
James well and Marina are back later now
Nexon and censored Britain's child
poverty crisis gets worse every day a
dinner lady from Lancashire broke down
in tears this weekend describing this is
unbelievable how she's been forced in
capitals to deny starving kids school
lunches that was it got to this I'm
coming back in three don't go anywhere
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
crisis continues to bite millions of
households across the country the
October energy price cap has been
confirmed to rise by 80 percent
inflation is now at 10.1 percent the
highest since Feb 82 and let's not
forget the spiraling cost of food at the
supermarket the highest since the global
financial crash in 2008 but now the
effect on children has been laid utterly
bare by an amazing dinner lady from
Lancashire over the weekend says that
she's been forced forced to turn away
hungry kids take a look at this
when I first started a year ago okay
once a month the map you know parents
forget to put money on at the beginning
of the month and you get that but now
you're talking 10 to 15 children a shift
every day every single day and I'm
saying you can't have that there's no
money and I'm just dreading going back
to work I'm dreading October and to be
honest it's getting to the point where
I'm just like I don't even think I can
do this job anymore I didn't take the
job on to starve children I'm sorry it's
just
Great Britain 2022 I'm now joined by
head teacher says the fine co-founder of
Britain's largest Food Bank Ray Wilford
welcome gentlemen
um can you explain to me Serge when you
see that kids in 2022 going to school
and not being able to have lunch what's
that like what's the reality of that I'm
sorry that's bad management and lack of
common sense you know if there's one
place where children shouldn't want for
anything it's in school for what I feel
sorry for the dinner lady being put in
that position where she has to decide
shouldn't happen they've got a past
routine pass it on let's find out what's
going on at home what's happening but
what do you do in that situation you're
you're a head teacher what are you doing
a situation simple you feed them and you
find out what the hell's going on if
necessary if they if they haven't
applied for free School meals because
the forms are wrong or whatever it is
but you feed the kids on every occasion
and the younger they are the more
important it is it's Common Sense any
responsibility from parents oh God yes
that's the second step first of all you
Safeguard the kids you make sure they
get their dinner then you find out why
the money is not there and in this
present climate yeah if the money isn't
there and it's not going to be there
what do you do as the head carry on
feeding them but you find out and if
necessary get Social Services involved
to find out how they can be helped in a
far more sensible way but you carry on
fees two pound twenty a day you carry on
feeding the kids and that's as simple as
that common sense as I said two things
here I can't believe that any head
teacher would put the dinner lady in
such a decision in the first place it's
all wrong Ray Walford um first of all
I'm going to say this people like you uh
deserve everything co-founder Britain's
largest Food Bank you said the reality
of that video is it's worse than that
it's much much worse I mean to start
with we shouldn't have any
discrimination in school places children
that are hungrier children that are
going hungry and that's right the way
across the Spectrum it's not people
sitting at home at benefits it's people
who have parents that have low paid jobs
parents who are self-employed people
that run pubs the crisis we're facing at
the moment it's worse than we went
through under covid under covert we had
support structures the energy crisis
that is kicking in at the moment is
forcing Community organizations to go
bust the cost of the energy that we're
actually having to to pay to run our
fridges has gone now from 68 pounds a
month to a project projected cost of 30
000 pounds next year she told me and and
you you feed 3 000 people whereabouts is
your food bank well we're based in
duckford and South East London we're one
of the few Banks food banks in Britain
which is open seven days a week we feed
pets and children and that ethos is to
feed and support anybody that walks
through our door in crisis that means
that we do people that got small
businesses we do pensioners we do have
you notice a total increase of and don't
take this the wrong way but anybody now
is going to a food bank it seems far
more people you tell my team
um with everything going on I could be
closed by Christmas we are so desperate
I mean cooking oil has gone from one
pound to two pound 19 in less than six
months where are we going as food bank
we're trying to appeal at the moment to
raise 25k to get through next year our
food bank isn't about dependency we're a
charity that works to tackle debt to
tackle advice to tackle mental health to
give people clothes to support their
pets that their pets do not end up at
Battersea dogs home we support them in
every way we give our children underwear
so that can go to school with a school
uniform and a pair of pants we give
homeless people a pair of socks to go
with the shoes that people give them
with we support elderly people that have
families around us hello do me do me a
favor how angry I'll bring you in a
second search what needs to be done how
I mean you're there in depth for doing
your bit out the kindness of your heart
and people's charity and generosity and
we keep doing these stories every single
night and people go oh is it good it is
that bad what what needs to happen we've
got a new prime minister on Monday we
one of the crucial things is the
government will always tell us pouring
money into the system the problem is
that local money that's put into the
food sector it's given to local
authorities and the money is not
allocated to organizations that are at
Grassroots level based on the numbers of
people they feed so there's
organizations in my Borough that look
after 33 people that have refrigerated
lorries that get thousands of pounds in
funding because they're a cool charity
and we that feeds anybody that walks
through our door can't get any funding
because we're based in lewisham we have
women with their children coming from
eight other boroughs to our food bank
because they're too frightened to report
to their schools that their children are
going hunger and if they do they're
fright and their kids will go into
what's your response because that's just
appalling isn't it and some I mean
honest to God something has to be done
doesn't it well the thing is for me it's
about safeguarding kids you know and
school's the right place to go if you've
got a problem yep I always go to your
food but let the school know any good
head in a good school will help all they
can and let's get some proper
communication going on would you report
a chart if you had real concerns about
them it's my duty to do so because I
mean and I've got a great pastoral team
we're going to knock in on doors if
necessary especially during covet but
let's find out what's going on we must
ignore the fact that since some bad
parenting going on and poor
prioritization of the money they have
that's been going on for donkey's years
people don't like to hear that right
that is that is I mean that is no I I
disagree I mean I totally of course in
every society you'll have poor people
that will treat the system in the same
way rich people avoid their tax the
reality is in Britain today people on
Universal Credit if they're young they
get less than 300 pounds a month that's
not enough to carry their electricity
bill if they're on Universal Credit they
get less than 600 pounds anybody living
in London no you cannot live and run
your family on 600 pounds a month it's
scoundless to blame the poor who have
zero money and pensioners who have fixed
fixed incomes can I not be responsible
for managing many don't have money to
budget that's the crisis I I understand
that and I understand what you're saying
sir it's just both of you briefly if you
can what is the answer well the answer I
can only talk about schools I don't know
very many cleverer people than me can't
come up the answer but I think schools
should be places of safety if there's a
problem with the kid put them first
don't confront them with it okay it's
embarrassing enough you know there's
plenty of ways of doing and helping
families and kids in particular without
anybody you know I've been doing it for
years good head teachers that I know do
it for years you know let's not be too
negative with the kids adults you can
get on with whatever you want you know
but keep it away from the kids they get
enough negativity we've had decade of it
now I had two sets of exam results I can
tell you Jeremy all right two great days
you should have seen those kids proud of
getting their exam results looking for
the future the diet they're getting at
the moment from everybody it seems never
mind social media
is negativity and down we've got to
change it for the kids right briefly
briefly the big problem we've got to
take in with this energy crisis in
particular is community groups
pensioners lunch and clubs food banks
everywhere needs emergency support
Nationwide because there's no points
telling people to go to the food bank
because come Christmas we will be all
bust unless we raise 25k by Christmas we
will have to close our door that's the
reality around the UK we are the front
line and if nobody supports the front
line we're going to have people dying of
starvation in the doorways of Britain I
am I have to say I would have listened
to somebody like you some years ago and
thought it was it was over the top I
don't believe it's over the top at all I
think you search are a unique human
being but I'm afraid we're in a
situation where this entire country and
and when it comes to kids that takes it
to another level but when it's
pensioners kids whoever gets that job
next Monday and everybody in the polls
says it will be Liz trust has got a hell
of a job on their hands and and
something thing needs to be done and it
needs to be done now thank you both very
much indeed right next and uncensored
it's highly High wokey no another
classic British sitcom slap with a
trigger warning when will it damn well
end Jess's Journal is the next we're
coming right back
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
TV host and Legend James well and
political commentator Marina Perkins
you're back uh let's get straight to it
Gorbachev uh yesterday dying 91 uh
inside Russia not much sympathy but
across the world seen as a man who
really bought change ended the Cold War
um he had a legacy didn't he he didn't
it's actually sad to see another one of
the good guys full basically
um he was the guy that made the West
um oh well opened up rush to the West
which is why he had that Pizza Hut
advert that everyone's obviously um very
fond of and any piece of Express but
yeah
um sad actually but but puts in very
lukewarm and when you consider what
Gorbachev does and then what Putin's
doing I think I think it was sad he was
91 so had quite good Innings yeah and I
think he did a lot of good for the world
not just for Russia I agree uh but Putin
is going to ruin the world if he hasn't
stopped fairly soon and I think
unfortunately I thought that the Russian
people might turn against him but it
doesn't look like they doesn't know that
at all um this is bizarre but there you
go 1980s sitcom Heidi Heidi hi holy holy
huh yeah good has been slapped with a
new trigger warning on Brit Box nobody
watches that do they uh the Sunday
night's staple finding the ups and downs
of Holiday Camp workers Heidi hi I love
Gladys and then he said Emmanuel now
viewers are warned of language and
attitudes of an era that may offend
James whale what is wrong with people
who offend I mean for goodness sake if
you've got nothing better do it in your
lives just just find something you know
a little offense fine maybe you'll get
really upset Heidi hi guys
what is wrong with what are we not
nothing is wrong with the world do you
get upset when someone slaps an 18 on a
movie
I don't even look at them right so just
don't ignore
ignore it again
with anything all right Gladys but I
think the problem is that you know you
it's not just an 18 on a movie it's
everything it's like every piece of uh
of work at University if it's considered
to be even Shakespeare even some of
these great things you might upset a
student well good because if you don't
get upset at that age how are you going
to manage as an adult well more upset
Gary lineker who seems to be able to
work for the BBC in a lot of money and
say whatever has seen a BBC journalist
since they apologize to lenniker after
accusing him of breaching impartiality
over comments criticizing the government
uh Neil Henderson BBC home in a foreign
news editor who asked Indica do you have
the freedom to tweet about this sort of
thing I thought they were rules he seems
to be one rule for everybody else at the
BBC that BBC that Dreadful organization
it'll be gone soon worry not right can I
just can I just say something if
something is crap objectively crap you
can say it's crap and that doesn't mean
you're not being impartial it just means
you're being objective yeah but he's a
bit like Lewis Hamilton he sits in his
big mansion criticizing everybody
doesn't he live Everybody's Got a
Mansion I know but it just doesn't he
annoys me at what point of wealth are
you allowed
and I thought the BBC weren't allowed to
do that they're so duplicitous
what is it everybody likes about Gary
lineker He's sort of a bit wet and a bit
weird because he's not very into
standing up for the good of the Common
People the common people as in common
common people as in common as in all of
us together everyone every day you might
be gone I don't like to consider myself
Gary linick is just I don't understand
why everybody is it just because it's
football and lots of people like
football because you can have a monkey
on there or some other animal on there
and he's using it to push a positive but
the new bastard the British bloated
company I ate him he said that they
weren't allowed to do that but linica
seems to get away with it that's the
point I apologize
who puts 400k into the Tory party oh
that's all right though isn't it no I
didn't say why are you saying that to me
I don't think that's right it's all very
quickly hang on well unions put loads of
money into the labor party why shouldn't
those people
reunions where again are trying to
achieve something for the greater good
okay
we're not talking about donors like Lord
questions what we need is Margaret
Thatcher back here again if they don't
let me cloned her the best prime
minister that ever existed what do you
make of that and just very quickly it
doesn't matter Boris is farewell
tomorrow uh it's my farewell on this
show appears is back on Monday so I'm
going to pack my stuff a bit like Boris
he's doing a lovely tour he went with
the what'd you make just one sentence
how do you sum up Boris Johnson's tenure
disastrous there's one word James
entertaining do you not think politics
will be a little bit duller without him
can you imagine I trust and I can't wait
dear Stars
bet you he's back please no this is
interesting though because a lot of
people are saying she'll make him the
envoyage the Ukraine and then in two
years when there's a hung Parliament
he'll rise again like a phoenix can you
look at her face can play horror like
Trump he's probably going to be back too
well you can't go worse than the one
they've got now okay listen don't stop
because Marina will get upset thank you
both I know it was a shortened version
James thank you very much indeed good
luck uh Marina thank you
11th of October good to me there you go
well listen hopefully not tonight uh
that's it from me thank you to Marina
thank you to James whatever you're up to
don't forget he told me to say make sure
you keep it uncensored have a great
night we're back tomorrow at 8. Tara
[Music]
I'm Tonya Dunn and this is talktv the
most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited
has to be interviewing president Trump
in the open Watson White House
particularly little red button he had on
his desk I have no idea what he did his
interview went on I wondered was to
launch a nuclear strike on North Korea
or open up a shot pit that I've been
falling to turn out he pressed it right
at the end of the interview and then
walked to Butler with a tray and
carrying planting it was the dark Cooper
this is talk TV news
or Suleiman Ryan Giggs is facing a
possible retrial after a jury failed to
reach a verdict on any of the charges
against him the former Manchester United
footballer denied head-butting his
ex-girlfriend using controlling and
coercive Behavior against her over a
three-year period and assaulting her
younger sister the new prime minister
will travel to Balmoral in Scotland to
meet the queen after taking over next
week she usually appoints new leaders
from Buckingham Palace or Windsor Castle
and food prices are rising at the
fastest rate in 14 years with overall
costs up 9.3 percent this month the
British retail Consortium blames the war
in Ukraine
well that's all for now we'll have more
after the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]